foreign
don't mind me just trying to make my own
connector for a Tesla charger see ther
recently released the blueprints for its
charging connector which it's now
calling the North American charging
standard and it means that pretty much
anyone can now try and build this thing
not that I'm actually trying this is
part of an old washing machine but why
is Tesla whose cars dominate the uscv
market now opening up their charger
design for Rivals to build let me
explain
okay first you need to understand what
different charges are out there and why
back when Tesla released its Roadster
there wasn't really a standard for
charges that combined alternating and
direct current charging so the company
began designing one eventually landing
on the design that Now features on its
us supercharger Network around the same
time though the rest of the industry was
developing its own charging designs now
you don't need to know all of them as
there are quite a few and drivers have
ended up with countless adapters to
charge their cars at different types of
stations but what you do need to know is
that most automakers in North America
converge towards this the combined
charging system or CCS it's obviously
bigger and bulkier than Tesla's design
now Tesla technically allowed other
automakers to use the design for its
smaller charger but they could only do
so through Tesla's patent pledge which
essentially means that you can use
Tesla's patents as long as Tesla can use
yours no automaker did that so fast
forward to today and the US is a tale of
two charges there are less than ten
thousand CCS charging stations designed
to charge Vehicles produced by the vast
majority of America's automakers but
there are more than 27 000 Tesla
charging stations designed to charge
Vehicles made by just one company so why
is Tesla suddenly sharing the design for
its charging connector without making
automakers sign up to that patent pledge
well according to Tesla's blog post the
move is to accelerate the world's
transition to sustainable energy but
there could be some other reasons why an
automaker might want to do this now one
is funding because our infrastructure
law provides 7.5 billion dollars 7.5
billion dollars to build a national
network of 500 000 electric vehicle
charging stations Across America now to
be eligible for that funding those
charges must be able to charge more than
one brand of vehicle and that's
something Tesla Chargers currently can't
do unless you get some third-party
adapter is involved but if another
automaker were to put a Tesla charging
port on their vehicle hey Presto Tesla
could potentially be eligible for
funding still right now it's just Tesla
using this charging port so why name it
the North American charging standard or
nacs well Tesla didn't respond to my
request for comment but it could be
something related to this Apple's
lightning cable see over in Europe this
guy is being phased out this is the past
and this is the present that's because
all new smartphone charges in the EU
have to be USBC from 2024 as the block
tries to standardize charging cables and
in Europe ccs2 has pretty much become
the standard for all EVS including
Teslas now back in the US the Biden
Administration is trying to do something
similar and create one EV charging cable
to rule them all but that's kind of hard
when as I pointed out most us automakers
use One charging standard whereas most
vehicles on U.S roads use another by
naming its cable the standard and citing
how popular their charger is Tesla seems
to be pitching to become the US Standard
but if the US were to adopt CCS as its
charging standard that could create a
headache for Tesla as the company might
have to adapt its vehicles and charges
so is Tesla's North American charging
standard likely to become an actual
standard and will it be adopted by any
other automaker well according to
Automotive analysts it's unlikely going
to see major automakers adopt this
standard after they've invested money
into deploying CCS on their vehicles
however one automaker has said that
they're going to put Tesla's charging
port on their vehicle solar EV startup
aptera the company actually ran a
campaign to get Tesla's charger to be
acknowledged as the U.S standard and
said they'll use necs on their vehicle
but will that be enough for Tesla to
receive federal funding well the federal
highways Administration told me they
were still finalizing the minimum
standards and requirements for funding
EV charges but they said that the final
rule would support charges that are
interoperable between different EVs and
EV charging companies for now at least
there's going to continue to be a mix of
charging Types on U.S roads unless I can
invent a new standard
[Music]